ravi de vous retrouver sur public sénat
hier les sénateurs ont entamé l'examen
d'une proposition de loi déposée par le
groupe communiste pour la sauvegarde de
l'audiovisuel public
en 2009 la publicité a été supprimée
après 20 heures sur le service public
fin 2011 la suppression de la publicité
doit être totale mais de nombreuses voix
s'élèvent à droite comme à gauche pour
le maintien de la publicité en journée
principale raison invoquée la fragilité
du financement de france télévisions
mais également son indépendance
les sénateurs communistes réclament
également la suspension de la
privatisation de la régie publicitaire
de france télévisions tout de suite dans
deux directions à l'hémicycle du sénat
bonne séance à tous l'ordre du jour
appelle la discussion de la proposition
de loi visant à assurer la sauvegarde du
service public de la télévision
présentée par monsieur jack ralite et
les membres du groupe crc spg
dans la discussion générale la parole et
à monsieur jacques khalid auteur de la
proposition de loi
vous avez la parole chers collègues
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je
commencerai mon intervention par un
rappel de mes propos ici même le 10 mai
dernier
je le fais notamment parce que ce jour
là nous étions peu mais même très peu or
j'aime l'information et la pensée des
battues disputer je vous sais en attente
d'un diagnostic le mien partagé par
nombre de parlementaires de tous bords
disait dit ceci premièrement le 4 avril
2007 à la rencontre mon engagement pour
la culture organisée par nicolas sarkozy
alors candidat
celui ci dit il faut être ambitieux pour
notre télévision et notamment pour les
chaînes publiques
c'est un fait l'audiovisuel public est
actuellement sous financée deuxièmement
le 21 mai 2008 à la commission copé à
laquelle je participais avec mon
collègue yvon renard et nous l'avons
quitté
je déclare au plan financier la
télévision publique n'est pas assuré de
son avenir
c'est comme si les parents d'un enfant
avait décidé de ne plus le reconnaître
aucune entreprise privée elle
accepterait la situation faite à france
télévisions troisièmement le 3 mars 2009
le conseil constitutionnel valide la loi
sur l'audiovisuel sous la réserve
expresse considérant 9 que la
suppression de la publicité sur france
télévisions soit compensé chaque année
sous peine d'affecter son indépendance
quatrièmement le 14 octobre 2009 la cour
des comptes estime que je cite la
situation financière est prévisionnel du
groupe est très fragile cinquièmement le
7 avril 2010
la nouvelle commission culturelle de
l'assemblée nationale organise une table
ronde fort suivi je l' ai d'ailleurs
j'ai d'ailleurs assisté ou la majorité
des propos rejoint mes conclusions
sixièmement
le 10 mai 2010 lors du débat sur
l'application de la loi relative à la
communication audiovisuelle et au
nouveau service public de télévision
notre collègue hervé maurey du groupe
centriste qui a voté la loi en 2009
déclare en ce qui concerne la question
des financements qui nous inquiétait il
ya un an la situation m semble-t-il
beaucoup moins satisfaisante
ce même jour notre collègue socialiste
david assouline qui n'a pas voté la loi
fait une forte intervention sur la
situation financière de l'audiovisuel
public
incontestablement est gravement
fragilisé tout ceci explique
certainement que les engagements
gouvernementaux de créer un comité de
suivi de la loi et un groupe de travail
sur la modernisation de la redevance
n'est pas été honorées le diagnostic est
clair le financement de la télévision
publique ne peut rester en l'état et
appel des décisions immédiates car il ne
s'agit pas d'un pression mais des
réalités suivantes premièrement tf1
bouygues continue contexte-là basque
continue de contester la taxe sur la
publicité
malgré un vrai redressement et a saisi
l'europe
deuxièmement l'europe a tout contesté la
taxe de 0 9% sur les opérateurs de
communications électroniques
il s'agit de 400 millions et la nature
de la dotation budgétaire de 450
millions d'euros attribuée par l'état à
france télévisions en 2009 le régime
fiscal tva appliquée à l'internet
qu'elle souhaite voir passer de 5 5 à 19
5% notamment dans le cas des abonnements
triple play 60 à 100 millions d'euros
qui vont à la création française et
audiovisuelle deviendrait manquants
enfin l'aide envisagée par l'état pour
le développement global media parce
qu'il s'agit d'un marché concurrentiel
et que ces ressources doivent têtes de
caractère privé bref l'ensemble je dis
bien l'ensemble des modalités de
compensation de la publicité est
contestée l'état lui même a réduit de 30
5 millions
les 450 millions nous avions voté
indiquant ainsi qui sanctionne au lieu
de récompenser les performances
réalisées par france télévisions et
c'est sur ce terrain financier
entièrement fragilisé 800 millions à 1
milliard d'euros sont en question qu
interviendra le plan dit non rigueur de
messieurs sarkozy et fillon
va-t-il être appliquée comme en france
télévisions en 2011
un exemple le sénat a décidé d'une
indexation de la redevance et a été
suivie que va-t-il se passer
on nous dit qu'une mission kanem
catherine morin desailly va rendre un
rapport qui auraient toutes les couleurs
le mien et empalot insuffisant encore
faudrait-il que cette minutie
prospective n'est pas en d'autres temps
choisi un chemin moins exigeants voire
complaisante
en effet comment s'expliquer qu'il
faille faire un travail de chercheur au
centime d'euro près pour envisager de ne
pas supprimer la publicité diurne
alors que à peine étaient intervenus le
vote de la loi
il a suffi aux lobbys bouygues tf1 de
quelques interventions autoritairement
pleureuses pour que la taxe d'émanations
gouvernementale a ratifié par le
parlement passe de 3 à 1,5 pour cent
puis à 0 5%
et cela alors que tf1 gagnait par la
loure une deuxième coupure publicitaire
le passage de leur glissant alors
d'horloge une figurine 9000 par heure
contre 7 auparavant
ainsi que la possibilité de racheter
deux chaînes de la tnt à des prix
défiant toute concurrence
labruyère dans debian fortune avait
raison s'il est vrai que les riches
soient colère c'est que la moindre chose
puisse leur manquer ou que quelqu'un
veuille leur résister il y a aussi des
personnes qui ne veulent pas revenir sur
la suppression totale de la publicité
étant donnée son omniprésence
antérieures aboutissants une insatiable
mercantilisation des programmes on peut
s'expliquer ce parti pris c'est un vieux
débat mais dans une proposition de loi
relative à l'audiovisuel enregiste
et à la présidence du sénat le 22 avril
1999 sont ma signature et l'abhorré
pendant six mois par une trentaine de
personnes faisant et aimant la
télévision on peut lire à l'article 6
les missions spécifiques du service
public constitue le fondement d'un
financement mixte dont bénéficie le
service public de l'audiovisuel le
financement public et pluri annuel du
service public de l'audiovisuel est
assis sur la redevance et des aides
publiques décidées en fonction de
contrats d'objectifs conclues entre
l'état le service public de
l'audiovisuel le financement privé du
service public de l'audiovisuel repose
sur les ressources publicitaires et la
création de nouveaux services afin de
garantir l'indépendance elle reste fait
des missions du service public de
l'audiovisuel
l'organisme collecteur de ressources
publicitaires est séparé des services de
programmation les clauses contractuelles
des contrats de publicité le peuvent
être fondées sur l'audience des
émissions mais seulement sur des
critères prenant en compte leur de
diffusion pour l'ensemble des sociétés
de programmes du service public de
l'audiovisuel le temps consacré à la
diffusion de messages publicitaires ne
peut être supérieure à 5 minutes par
période de 60 minutes la perte de
recettes est intégralement compensés par
l'état
ainsi pour les auteurs de cette
proposition loi qui n'a eu droit qu'à
trois minutes d'examen d'ailleurs au
sénat la publicité participe un
financement croisé qui plafonnait et
réguler strictement devient même partie
prenante de la garantie de liberté et
d'indépendance pour l'audiovisuel public
mais il faut aller plus loin pour
analyser le blocage fondamental que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui sur le maintien
de la publicité diurne
c'est à dire sur les finances de la
télévision publique
il suffit de rapprocher deux
déclarations la cour des comptes du 14
octobre 2009 à 10 plus que la situation
financière difficile
je cite les questions liées au périmètre
du groupe
au nombre des chaînes publiques et au
genre qui sont présentés ne saurait être
exclue de l'évaluation de la réforme
dans son livre intitulé libre publiée en
2001 nicolas sarkozy écrivait la
question du périmètre du service public
est elle bien réelle
je suis convaincu que nous pourrons
maintenir tout à la fois france 2 france
3 arte et la fin kien par mois de quatre
chaînes nationales de service public qui
pèchent souvent par un grave déficit de
complémentarité et d'identification
cette abondance quantitative met en jeu
la pérennité du service public car elle
se construit au détriment de la qualité
parce que ces chaînes se concurrence
entre elles sur le terrain de l'audience
et parce qu'elle s'épuise à se partager
un budget qui n'est forcément pas
extensible à l'infini
c'est dans ce contexte que doit être
évoqué la question de la privatisation
de france 2 on peut lire utilement sur
cette problématique
le livre blanc de f fin 2007 le rapport
de daniel iché hadji au président de la
république les médias il numérique
septembre 2008 et le média choc d'alain
minc en 92 qui traitant de la régulation
audiovisuelle la qualifie de remède de
cheval version droite
à la lecture de ces déclarations
néolibérale on peut légitimement se
poser une question
l'arrêt de résistance constatés ici et
là au maintien de la publicité diurne
donc au déficit programme est assuré de
la terre organisé de la télévision
publique ne cache-t-elle pas une volonté
de privatisation d'une partie du secteur
sous une forme à débattre et qui
pourrait passer par le mot à la mode
aujourd'hui de la coopération entre le
privé et le public
pendant que se développe une politique
de soutien au déploiement de grands
groupes audiovisuels privés français
promu
champion c'est jean marie messier qui a
montré la voie
et s'il a échoué dans une quasi faillite
je rappelle d'ailleurs à la haute
assemblée l'opposition de la majorité à
toute enquête sur le pourquoi de la
chute de j6m système entraînant c'est
vivant dit la cascade de difficultés
qu'on a connus mais surtout se précisait
alors la définition aujourd'hui affinée
de la politique historique comme la
nomme nicolas sarkozy des champions
nationaux lancés sous le gouvernement
balladur de 1993 à travers la loi
carignon de 1994 que nicolas sarkozy mis
en oeuvre durant une année comme
ministre de la communication
l'universitaire pierre musso grands
spécialistes de toutes ces questions
commente cela revient à distinguer d'à
côté secteur public géré comme une
entreprise mais connoté par l'emprise
politique aux états tic et de l'autre un
secteur privé considéré comme un
champion
partant à la conquête des marchés
extérieurs le néo libéralisme sarkozien
à pour le gordien cette nouvelle
dialectique de l'état et du marché 1 et
à gérer comme une entreprise et des
entreprises champions soutenu par l'état
néolibéral sur un marché mondialisé le
philosophe pierre legendre a bien raison
de dire la paix gestionnaire est une
guerre dans laquelle le droit des
affaires est une pointe avancée du
management mais je ne résiste pas à
illustrer ainsi le compagnonnage et à
marcher que l'état actuel elysées et
gouvernement s'évertue à cacher en
faisant du marché un deus ex machina au
lieu d'avouer qu'il est quasi membres du
gouvernement lequel travaillent pour lui
tout en décochant de temps à autre des
flèches verbal à son endroit
je trouve à la limite de l'impudeur la
petite phrase gouvernementale rencontrer
partout c'est pas moi c'est pas nous
c'est le marché je trouve cela insultant
pour les citoyens par exemple
je connais mon oncle ma cousine mon
voisin
beaucoup d'entre vous chers collègues
sénateurs je m'aime bien connu georges
marchais mais je n'ai jamais rencontré
le marché qui n'est pas comme disait car
le pauliani dans la grande
transformation un état de nature mais
une pure construction de la société et
je fais même set je fais mienne cette
remarque de myriam revault d'allonnes ce
qui caractérise le néolibéralisme c'est
que l'économie de marché n'est plus un
principe de limitation de l'état mais le
principe de régulation interne de bout
en bout de son existence et de son
action en sorte que l'état est sous
surveillance du marché et non l'inversé
j 6 n 10 est adoré cette phrase de rené
char impose ta chance serre ton bonheur
et va vers ton risque at regarder ils
s'habitueront non nous ne nous habitue
rompt jamais c'est pourquoi nous
demandons un vote oui un vote est pas
une esquive un renvoi en commission sur
le maintien de la publicité diurne et
sur cinq autres objectifs garantissant
au niveau nécessaire
les financements du service public et
son indépendance
d'ailleurs quand je dis son indépendance
je viens de voir ce matin dans la
correspondance que nous recevons les uns
et des autres que l'ancienne directrice
de cabinet de monsieur sarkozy vient
d'être nommé pdg d'une société dont
l'essentiel de l'activité et les marques
et la production audiovisuelle donc la
dépendance n'est pas un mots coquins cet
amour réel les sports mais il était
comment dirais-je étant donné la gravité
de la situation le maintien de la
publicité en journée ne saurait à lui
seul garantir un service public de
l'audiovisuel digne de ce nom
aussi est il indispensable de solliciter
d'autres leviers de financement
cela implique d'agir sur la contribution
à l'audiovisuel public en rétablissant
la justice l'assujettissement des
résidences secondaires à cette
contribution
c'est l'article 5 de notre projet mais
le seigneur s'était prononcé dans ce
sens vous vous en rappelez en outre
notre démarche de sauvegarde du service
public de la télévision ne saurait faire
l'impasse sur la participation des
chaînes de télévision privées dont le
taux de taxation des revenus
publicitaires serait portée à 5 %
article 6 tout cela était bien sûr la
suspension immédiate de la privatisation
de la régie publicitaire article 3 que
le conseil d'administration de france
télévisions a majoritairement écoutant
ce qu'a dit le conseil constitutionnel
parlementaires y compris donc sénateurs
déjà reportée enfin article 4
l'indépendance décisionnel éditoriale et
de programmation de la société france
télévisions implique qu'aucune
instruction écrite ou orale de puisse
être adressées par le pouvoir exécutif à
france télévisions qui arbitrent seul et
librement de cette décision en conseil
d'administration
celui ci désigne en faudra bien revenir
un jour seul son président c'est
pourquoi nous demandons un vote oui un
vote
osant une télévision publique dont le
sens profond être se libérer des seules
règles d'un jeu qui ne serait qu
économiquement profitable et socialement
tolérable qui se nourrit de valeur à
leur exacte de la conscience qu'il
laisse aucun problème sur la touche qui
va au devant des désirs et plaisir des
savoirs et vouloir des citoyens et des
créateurs elle veut que la pensée et
l'imaginaire ne reste pas à quai mais
gagne la haute mer là où le vent est
favorable à l'aventuré humaine dans la
télévision est partie prenante dès
qu'elle n'a pas l'imprudence ou
l'impudence de mépriser les rêves
qu'elle choisit autres choses que la
morale du présent asservissantes de
l'énergie d'avenir qu'elle refuse
d'ignorer que la pensée avant d'être v
trajet et que l'universel c'est le local
sans les murs nous voulons contribuer à
donner un départ nouveau pour la
les visions à l'image de ce qu'arthur
rimbaud disait j'ai tendu des cordes de
clocher en clocher des guirlandes de
fenêtre à fenêtre des chaînes d'or des
toiles à étoiles et je danse
je le remercie chaque collègue
oui oui vous êtes maintenant rapporteur
monsieur le rapporteur vous avez la
parole alors monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
c'est en tant que rapporteur de la
proposition de loi du groupe crc spg
assurer la sauvegarde du service public
de la télévision que j'interviens
présentement
d'abord pour dire que la majorité de la
commission n'a pas adopté
ces propositions dont je viens de parler
pour deux raisons principales
premièrement elle déclare attendre le
rapport de contrôle budgétaire de la
télévision qu'elle fait actuellement
deux concerts avec la commission des
finances jeudi au passage que de plus en
plus la commission des finances
intervient dans la vie des autres
commissions et on l'a vu par exemple sur
la comment dirais je
la taxe qui avait été avancée pour la
numérisation et bien après il ya eu un
rapport qui s'est développée et dans la
presse on a dit le sénat n'est ce pas m
google
ben je connais ici beaucoup de monde et
sur beaucoup de bon en tout cas sûr de
ce côté là et qui ne sont pas d'accord
avec google donc premièrement voilà ce
que l adie deuxièmement elle est
attachée à la suppression totale en tout
cas certaine ses membres à la publicité
qui doit être non présentes sur la
totalité des écrans de la télévision
publique
ça c'était ma première remarque donnait
été constatée n'est ce pas mais j'en
veux faire d'autres graves sur la
procédure des ppl de cette ppl procédure
sur laquelle s'est appuyée la majorité
de la commission les affaires
culturelles pour exprimer son désaccord
il est normal qu'une proposition loi
soit rapportée par un parlementaire de
même sensibilité que ses auteurs
pourtant la pratique que je viens d'en
avoir a fait chanceler
cette évidence tellement l'organisation
qu'impliquent ces ppl sortie de la
réforme constitutionnelle du 23 juillet
2008 est alambiquée ou me plaçant sur un
autre registre à presque une nuance
comique
je me souviens vous aussi sans doute
quand roger karoutchi alors ministre des
relations avec le parlement nous vantait
le bouger constitutionnel il l'a dit il
dit les fois c'est une révolution
répétait-il en refroidissant le mot
alors j'ai consulté le parcours
législatif offert au ppl compo vos pages
22 et 23 des guides pratiques
d'application de la révision
constitutionnelle au sénat sous
l'intitulé les nouvelles compétences de
la conférence des présidents
j'ai lu ceci les groupes de l'opposition
et les groupes minoritaires peuvent
demander c'est un droit de tirage
l'inscription d'un texte dans le cadre
du jour de séance qui leur est réservé
une fois par mois et selon les modalités
fixées par la conférence des présidents
ainsi que l'ont rappelé les présidents
de séance les 26 mars et 30 avril 2009
conformément à un accord conclu entre
les présidents de groupes et de
commissions est actée par la conférence
des présidents
les propositions loi ou de résolutions
inscrites à l'ordre du jour réservé son
discuter sur la base du texte initial
sauf souhait contraire du groupe
politique intéressé par ailleurs c'est
la troisième remarque sur cette question
je cite toujours même en cas de
désaccord de la commission sur
l'ensemble de la proposition doit ou de
résolution celle ci est examiné par le
sénat en séance publique article par
article sans qu'une question préalable
ou une exception d'irrecevabilité puisse
être déposée
et bien aujourd'hui renvoi en commission
c'est la question préalable
c'est ce droit de tirage que le groupe
crc spg applique
aujourd'hui scrupuleusement or la
commission a décidé tout en marquant je
le vois une certaine sympathie pour une
partie de mon propos qu'il y avait lieu
un renvoi en commission
autrement dit après un débat pour il n'y
aura pas de vote
c'est à dire pas d'acte alors que tout y
appelle urgemment comme je les démonter
dans mon intervention de présentation de
la ppn devant cette situation pour moi
imprévisible s'est interrogé alentours
est d'abord mon collègue thierry foucaud
qui vient de présenter une ppl sur le
bouclier fiscal lui a eu débat comme le
viala varin mais surtout vote grâce a
déclaré le président arthuys à la
courtoisie sénatoriales tiens tiens ma
ppl et privé porte de sortie tandis que
celle de thierry foucaud en bénéficient
nous ne sommes pas diviser bien
évidemment lui et moi et puis discutant
avec ma collègue isabelle pasquet qui
était intervenu sur la ppl relatives aux
assistants maternels le 14 janvier 2010
du groupe centriste entend groupe
minoritaire elle m'informe qu'elle avait
souhaité faire un renvoi en commission
mais il y avait renoncé parce que lui
avait fait comprendre ce n'était pas les
usages et ce n'était pas conforme aux
accords passés collectivement entre
présidents de groupes et de commissions
actée par la conférence des présidents
ceux qui rejetaient sans dire le renvoi
en commission
je me suis trouvée alors comme un skieur
au fond du bus qu'avait bien ma ppl pour
ne méritait ni courtoisie sénatoriales
ni bénéfices du consensus 10 ans et est
elle un coup de pioche
un moteur à explosion j'ai donné ma
langue au chat
et on l'a répondu aux membres de la
commission des affaires culturelles que
je suis depuis quinze ans que
premièrement le renvoi en commission
n'était pas interdite par écrit
deuxièmement il y aurait vote plus tard
un jour peut-être seulement quand la
mission de contrôle budgétaire commune
ou deux commissions des affaires
culturelles et des finances aurait
achevé son étude de la question en fait
dans la déclaration de la conférence des
présidents relatives au ppl il y à un
non-dit consensuel dont le résultat
peut-être l'expérience est là la
dilution de l'opposition
l'effacement de ses effets
d'intervention sont soit exercé la
moindre contrainte
le texte de cet alinéa a été trouvé mais
au point qu'il peut l'en sortir qu'un
sage alignement et bien je ne me suis
pas aligné et j'ai refusé de présenter
le renvoi en commission
c'est à dire que je n'ai pas accepté de
dire une chose et son contraire
d'autant que le 26 mars 2009 dans le
compte rendu intégral
on peut lire à propos de la première
application de la journée mensuelle
réservée aux groupes de l'opposition et
aux groupes minoritaires
je cite les présidents de groupe et deux
commissions se sont accordés au sein de
la conférence des présidents pour ne pas
adopter de conclusions négatives qui
couperait court à la discussion
ces articles je remercie le président le
gendre de s'être substituée à amour
quand il s'agira de présenter la le
renvoi en commission est une question
d'honnêteté de lui et moi je le dis
comme je le pense et je le dis très fort
il faut ajouter au texte de la
conférence des présidents qu'il ne peut
te pu y avoir de renvoi en commission
c'est précisément le sens du courrier
cadres et c'est la présidente de l'ong
route nicole borvo cohen seat au
président larcher qui lui a notamment
répondu le 18 mai ce site sa dernière
phrase non pas qu'elle soit la
conclusion de l'intégralité du courrier
mais sa dernière phrase la question de
principe mises en évidence par votre
courrier est à mes yeux du plus grand
intérêt
c'est pourquoi il me paraît très utile
si sarko ier votre assentiment
je suis sûr qu'ils aient déjà donné
c'est un sentiment que cette question
que cette soumises un groupe de travail
sur la réforme de notre règlement
plus généralement de quoi ont eu peu at
on eu peur quand le vote a été mis de
côté à la commission des affaires
culturelles je n'arrive pas à partager
ce refus de vote qui a bouté dans l'est
c'est à dire que la question ne sera pas
posée aujourd'hui je trouve que c'est
une restauration du fait majoritaire
dans une démarche censée définir les
droits de l'opposition parlementaire
ces dix ans et énonçant sûr
je vous remercie mon cher collègue la
parole et à monsieur frédéric mitterrand
ministre de la culture et de la
communication vous avez la parole
monsieur le ministre
monsieur le président monsieur le
président de la commission de la culture
de l'éducation et la communication du
sénat monsieur jacques legendre
monsieur le rapporteur mme suite la cre
a dit
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
hélas oui la réforme de l'audiovisuel
public lancé par monsieur le président
de la république est à mes yeux
essentielles et son enjeu va bien
au-delà de la seule sauvegarde de notre
audiovisuel public car la loi du 5 mars
2009 permet non seulement sa
pérennisation
mais également son renouveau et même sa
refondation
à l'initiative de la haute assemblée
nous avons il y a dix jours esquissé ici
même un premier bilan de la mise en
oeuvre de cette loi et je voudrais pour
commencer vous en restituer les
principales conclusions que j'en tire je
note tout d'abord que la suppression de
la publicité en soirée à libérer le
service public de la contrainte de
l'audience commercial cette suppression
était nécessaire à l'approfondissement
du virage hérite éditoriales engagées
par les dirigeants de france télévisions
que je tiens à saluer de nouveau virage
éditorial qui était d'ailleurs en gésine
en quelque sorte comme l'avait rappelé
david assouline sénateur david assouline
la télévision publique renoue ainsi avec
une exigence culturelle qui correspond à
sa vocation première et nous ne pouvons
tous que nous féliciter de voir par
exemple
en mars dernier les fausses confidences
de marivaux dans l'excellente mise en
scène du théâtre de la commune
d'aubervilliers présenté en première
partie de soirée sur france 2 et réunir
ainsi près de 2 millions de
téléspectateurs
car si les perspectives de recettes
publicitaires peser encore sur leur
choix de programmation
les dirigeants de france télévisions
aurait-il véritablement la liberté de
renouveau
et ce type d'expérience sachant que 2
millions de téléspectateurs représente
seulement si j'ose dire 9,6 part
d'audience contre les 15,8 que france 2
atteint en moyenne
ce mois là ainsi la notion perverse et
la tyrannie de dima d'audimat ne sont
plus la même contrainte qu'autrefois et
de la même manière les mêmes résultats
ont été obtenus pour la diffusion de la
pièce colombe de jean anouilh
il y a encore quelques jours certains
tout en reconnaissant de l'avancé pour
la liberté éditoriale que constitue la
suppression de la publicité en soirée
considère que nous pourrions mêmes
devrions en rester là
je pense au contraire que l'idée de
libérer totalement la télévision
publique de la contrainte de l'audience
commercial est toujours la bonne
notamment sur le créneau stratégique du
début de soirée entre 18h et 20h
par ailleurs je rappelle que la
suppression de la publicité est
largement reconnu par le public et
téléspectateurs et en ce sens il me
semble que france télévisions a très
bien réussi à marquer sa différence par
rapport à la télévision privée et qu'il
y a là un encouragement à continuer
résolument dans cette direction je
voudrais également revenir sur un sujet
que je sais un peu sensible mais qui à
mes yeux n'a rien n'est tabou c'est
celui des éditeurs privés de télévision
et notamment des nouvelles chaînes de la
tnt
leur développement est essentiel à la
fois parce qu'il contribuera au
pluralisme de l'offre mais parce qu'il
apportera aussi à la création française
des ressources financières
supplémentaires
en effet comme vous le savez fort bien
les chaînes de télévision finance
massivement notre création dans le cadre
d' obligations fixées par la
réglementation sur la base de leur
chiffre d'affaires
et il faut à l'évidence maintenir
ce dispositif vertueux pour cela il est
hautement souhaitable que le financement
de l'audiovisuel soit clarifiée c'est à
dire que la télévision publique soit
financée par des fonds publics et la
télévision privée par la publicité
voilà les raisons pour lesquelles le
gouvernement estime que la réforme doit
être menée jusqu'à son terme et que la
publicité commerciale doit disparaître
des services nationaux de france
télévisions il compris en journée cela
étant posé je tiens à répondre point par
point aux éléments qui vous inquiète
monsieur sénateurs et qui vous ont
conduit à déposer cette proposition de
loi concernant l'indépendance de france
télévisions tout d'abord et
singulièrement la procédure de
nomination de son président la loi du 5
mars 2009 et la loi organique adopté le
même jour ont modifié la procédure de
nomination du président de france
télévisions et plus largement des
sociétés nationales de programme par ces
nominations
il s'agit pour l'état actionnaire
d'assumer ses responsabilités et c'est
précisément ce que souhaitait le
président de la république
cette nouvelle procédure de nomination
offre de nombreuses garanties en
particulier la nomination par décret du
président de la république ne peut
intervenir qu'après avis conforme du
conseil supérieur de l'audiovisuel et
après avis des commissions
parlementaires chargées des affaires
culturelles dans chacune des deux
assemblées
elle a été une première fois mise en
oeuvre avec la nomination de monsieur
jean luc hess à la présidence de radio
france par un décret en conseil des
ministres du 7 mai 2009 vous y avez
d'ailleurs été étroitement associés
comme le prévoit la loi
cette nouvelle procédure a fait ses
preuves puisqu'elle a abouti à l'onu à
la nos ministes à la nomination d'un
professionnels aux compétences
remarquables et force est de constater
que l'indépendance des sociétés
nationales de programme concerné n'est
aucunement entamées
comme l'a d'ailleurs confirmé le conseil
constitutionnel la même sérénité le même
sérieux entoureront le choix de la
personne appelée à assurer la prochaine
présidence de france télévisions et
lorsque j'entends ou lorsque je lis ça
et là tout des jeux serait fait est que
le successeur éventuel de monsieur de
carolis seraient connus je m'étonne je
trouve que c'est faire peu de cas du
parlement et du conseil supérieur de
l'audiovisuel je souhaite en revanche
souligné deux points qui eux sont tout à
fait certains c'est d'abord mon total
accord avec le président de la
république
quant à notre ambition pour la prochaine
présidence de france télévisions sa
détermination comme la mienne sont qu'un
professionnel accompli conduisent france
télévisions verset télévision du 21e
siècle et porte haut les valeurs
fondamentales de l'excellence du service
public
c'est en second lieu que vous
parlementaires seraient régulièrement
associé à cette future nomination qui
représente un choix fondateurs pour
l'avenir de notre audiovisuel public
j'en viens à la gare entier du
financement de france télévisions qui
suscite également vos inquiétudes
je commence par vous dire que vous avez
raison d'estimer que l'indépendance de
france télévisions est lié aux garanties
et à la visibilité dont disposeront les
dirigeants sur le financement
eh bien ces garanties et cette
visibilité sont justement assuré par la
loi puisque de façon corrélée à la
suppression de la publicité le mode de
financement de france télévisions a
évolué pour compenser la perte des
recettes publicitaires
le législateur a en effet prévu que la
dotation issus de la contribution à
l'audiovisuel public c'est à dire la
redevance soit désormais complétée par
une dotation complémentaire
issu du budget général de l'état cette
évolution me semble rationnelle
raisonnable et pour tout dire père
curieuse
d'abord parce que le remplacement d'une
recette publicitaire incertaine par une
recette public assuré constitue pour
france télévisions un facteur
indiscutable de sérénité financière
edit variable mais aussi parce que le
financement de la réforme est bel et
bien prévu le montant de la ressource
publique à prévoir pour les années 2009
à 2012 figure noir sur blanc dans le
plan d'affaires de l'avènement de
l'avenant au contrat d'objectifs et de
moyens conclu entre la société publique
et l'état
il tient compte de l'ensemble des
paramètres dont la suppression de la
publicité en soirée en 2009 ainsi que à
partir de fin 2011
en journée j'en profite pour rappeler
que la loi prévoit donc la suppression
totale de la publicité sur france
télévisions au moment où la france aura
entièrement basculer dans la télévision
numérique c'est à dire justement fin
cette date n'a pas été choisie au hasard
l'extinction totale de la diffusion
analogique permettra de réaliser des
économies importantes sur les coûts de
diffusion qui limiteront d'autant le
besoin de financement complémentaires
apportés par l'état
quant à la révision de la dotation
budgétaire de france télévisions en 2009
permettez moi de vous apporter les
précisions suivantes
les faits d'abord france télévisions la
commission pour la télévision publique
et le gouvernement ont évalué en 2008 à
450 millions d'euros la dotation
budgétaire destiné à compléter le
financement de france télévisions le
plan d'affaires pour 2009 2012 finalisé
en mai 2009 a repris ce montant au
regard des estimations de recettes
publicitaires or il est apparu au cours
de l'année 2009 que les recettes
réellement encaissées dépasser largement
les prévisions la révision de la
dotation budgétaire de france
télévisions est donc tout ce qu'il ya de
plus logique et relève d'une saine
gestion des deniers publics d'une
gestion responsable qui sait tenir
compte des autres besoins de
l'audiovisuel cette réduction s'est
faite dans le respect de l'indispensable
retour à l'équilibré de france
télévisions la société a ainsi terminé
l'année 2009 avec un résultat positif
alors ce retour à l'équilibré
opérationnel n'était initialement prévu
que d'ici 2011
le troisième sujet d'inquiétude que vous
avez exprimées n'est pas fondée me
semble-t-il davantage
il concerne le dynamisme de la
contribution à l'audiovisuel public
bien que la dotation budgétaire complète
désormais le financement de france
télévisions la majeure partie de ce
financement continu à provenir du
produit de la contribution à
l'audiovisuel public
c'est pourquoi je partage pleinement
l'attention que vous lui portez et je me
félicite d'ailleurs du travail de la
mission lancée par le sénat sur
l'adéquation du financement de france
télévisions à ses moyens comme vous je
suis extrêmement attentifs aux
déterminants de l'ex redevance
audiovisuelle assiette de la
contribution à l'audiovisuel public
montant champ des bénéficiaires est bien
là encore les faits me semble tout à
fait clair la contribution à
l'audiovisuel public a été rehaussé de 2
euros en janvier 2010 et elle est depuis
2009 indexées sur l'inflation
ces mesures lui assure une solidarité
une solidité lui assure une solidité
ea dynamisme qui garantissent à notre
audiovisuel public
un final un financement forts et
pérennes
les recettes globales du compte de
concours financier alimenté par la
contribution à l'audiovisuel public ont
progressé de +3 7% entre 2008 et 2009 et
devrait connaître une nouvelle
progression de + 4 3 % en 2010 et de +
3% les trois années suivantes
un philosophe disait que le mouvement se
prouve en marchant je vous ai à la fois
montré le mouvement la progression des
ressources de l'audiovisuel public et je
vous en ai je crois indiquer les raisons
claires et distinctes
tous ces éléments sont je pense de
nature à vous rassurer quant au
dynamisme actuel et à venir de ses
ressources
vous vous souvenez vous souciez enfin
des taxes créées par la loi du 5 mars
le premier élément que je veux vous
indiquer d'emblée c'est qu'il n'ya pas
de lien d'affectation entre le
financement budgétaire de france
télévisions et les dite taxe puisque le
financement de france télévisions sur
lequel se concentrent à juste titre
notre attention aujourd'hui n'est pas
soumis à leur évolution
j'en profiterai néanmoins pour souligner
deux points qui me semble important
concernant ces deux taxes la taxe sur la
publicité télévisée a vu son taux réduit
en 2009 en raison des difficultés
économiques du secteur mais elle demeure
en dépit de cette réduction
conjoncturelle
quant à la taxe sur le chiffre
d'affaires des opérateurs de
communications électroniques
elle fait certes l'objet d'une
discussion avec la commission européenne
mais nous contestons les griefs notifiés
à ce sujet en tout état de cause je le
répète il n'existe pas de lien entre
cette taxe et le financement budgétaire
de france télévisions tous ces éléments
je l'espère sont de nature à vous
rassurer quant à l'avenir sera de la
télévision publique auquel je suis vous
le savez particulièrement attaché la loi
a été votée il ya un an
nous ne sommes qu'à la moitié du chemin
et nous devons mener cette réforme
jusqu'à son terme
ses conséquences notamment financières
sont parfaitement prise en compte ceux
dont france télévisions a besoin
aujourd'hui
tout comme l'ensemble du secteur
audiovisuel c'est de stabilité
législative et réglementaire
c'est précisément ce que lui garantit la
loi alors dans ce cadre renoncer à
l'ouverture du capital de la régie de
france télévisions serait tout à fait
contre-productif et pénaliserait les
salariés de la régie car ne rien faire
pour france télévisions publicité se
serait laissé dépérir un outil
industriel performant et mettre dans une
situation délicate d équipe solide et
compétente
seul le développement de l'activité de
la régie est à même de limiter les
effets d'une douloureuse restructuration
à cette fin france télévisions a fait le
choix d'ouvrir le capital de la régie un
partenaire industriel
le gouvernement approuve logiquement ce
choix responsables autres l'avenir des
salariés de france télévisions publicité
ce sont aussi les moyens dont pourra
disposer france télévisions qui
m'importe renoncer à l'ouverture du
capital de la régie mettrait également
en péril les perspectives de ressources
commerciales qui subsisteront après la
fin 2011
la publicité régionale le parrainage la
publicité sur internet leur
développement ne pourra s'appuyer que
sur une régie forte dynamique
c'est à dire ouverte à de nouveaux
horizons industriels
je vous rappelle enfin que la décision
d'ouvrir le capital de la régie ne
relève aucunement d'une demande de
l'état elle a été prise par la direction
de france télévision elle-même approuvé
par son conseil d'administration où
siègent à la fois des représentants de
l'état des parlementaires des
personnalités indépendantes nommé par le
csa et des représentants du personnel et
dont le rôle est de veiller aux intérêts
de l'entreprise
il s'agit là d'un processus
parfaitement transparent pour conclure
je rappellerai que le mouvement de
suppression de la publicité en journée
sur france télévisions dont nous
débattons aujourd'hui fait comme il se
doit
l'objet d'un processus d'évaluation
prévue par le législateur avant que la
suppression ne soit effective
le gouvernement devra remettre au
parlement au plus tard au plus tard le
1er mai 2011 un rapport sur l'impact de
la fin de la publicité en soirée qui
permettra de faire le point pour
l'ensemble ces raisons et compte tenu du
travail engagé par les sénateurs dans le
cadre de la mission sur l'adéquation du
financement de france télévisions à ses
moyens le gouvernement n'est pas
favorable à l'adoption de cette
proposition de loi
je vous remercie pour votre attention je
vous remercie monsieur de mise dans la
suite de la diffusion générale la parole
est à madame catherine morin desailly
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues comme vous
tous j'ai à coup j'ai écouté
attentivement l'exposé de notre collègue
jack ralite relatif à la proposition de
loi qu'il a déposé le 6 avril dernier
proposition de loi visant à assurer la
sauvegarde du service public de la
télévision
assurer la sauvegarde du service public
de la télévision c'est je crois notre
objectif commun qui d'ailleurs avait
mobilisé nombre d'entre nous de l'année
dernière sur le projet de loi relatif à
la communication audiovisuelle et au
nouveau service public de télévision
mais plutôt que sauvegarder
je préférerais qu'on utilise les mots
pérenniser et développer cartels et je
crois l'ambition que nous avons eu sinon
je vous le dis aujourd'hui je ne serai
pas autant battus pour l'indexation et
la revalorisation de la redevance et je
vous remercie encore chers collègues de
nous avoir suivis et michel thiollière
donc ce combat la pérennité et le
développement de france télévisions
repose bien entendu sur les financements
adéquats et la mesure à licques je vous
rejoins complètement je voulais dit en
commission mais aussi sur une gestion
stratégique de ceux ci sur une
différenciation accrue de l'offre du
service public par rapport à ses
concurrents sur sa capacité à mickey
rapidement désormais en média global
dans un paysage audiovisuel qui s'est
considérablement diversifié ces
dernières années notamment par l'arrivée
des chaînes de la tnt
face aux nouvelles pratiques générés par
le boom de l'internet et les innovations
technologiques la télévision publique
doit non seulement se moderniser
également s'est singularisé développer
une offre éditoriale originale de
qualité et attractive lui permettant
ainsi d'être un des grands vecteurs de
la culture pour chacun comme vous aimez
à l'affirmer monsieur le ministre la
soie avant tout les conditions de sa
survie chers collègues
si vous souhaitez parler ainsi mais il
faut avoir aussi une vision globale des
défis à relever qui même s'ils sont
primordiaux ne sont pas exclusivement
financier c'est pourquoi nous avons
adopté la loi du 5 mars 2009 avec des
dispositions permettant à france
télévisions cette adaptation que le
président patrick de carolis avait de
lui-même sagement engagé c'est donc cet
ensemble d'objectifs qu'il ne faut pas
perdre de vue si on souhaite voir
aboutir cette très forte bien engagée
bien engagé il est vrai mais encore au
milieu du gué attaché à la réussite de
la réforme le groupe centriste a jugé
bon qu'un débat sur sa mise en oeuvre
soit organisée dans le cadre de la
semaine réservée au contrôle
parlementaire car nous centristes sam
très attaché au rôle du parlement en
matière de contrôle de l'action
gouvernementale rendue possible par la
réforme de la constitution d'août 2008
vous reconnaîtrez monsieur ralik comme
vous nous jouons pleinement notre rôle
et que c'est sans complaisance que nous
avons réaffirmé nos exigences quant aux
mesures non appliquées et aux promesses
non tenues je pense notamment au comité
de suivi composée de quatre députés et
quatre sénateurs ainsi qu'au groupe de
travail sur la modernisation de la
redevance d'azur mais c'est le ministre
j'en profite pour vous demander une
réponse à ce propos que nous n'avons pu
obtenir le 10 mai dernier
nous avons aussi exposer nos
préoccupations devant l'incertitude
pesant sur les taxes que vous avez
largement évoquée même si elles ne sont
pas directement affecté
je prends monsieur le ministre à témoin
pour que la guerre est mort et a évoqué
la taxe sur les faillites
j'ai quant à moi souligné que l'effet
d'aubaine et escompté pour les chaînes
privées n'avaient pas été au rendez vous
et j'ai tout comme vous et comme chacun
ici parce que nous sommes tous des élus
responsables exprimer mes inquiétudes
face au contexte économique très dégradé
due à la crise nous avons donc exprimé
nos inquiétudes sur les modalités du
financement de groupes france
télévisions
c'est pourquoi aussi en tant que
rapporteur
j'ai tenu à vous rappeler les
précautions que nous avions prises à
l'époque avec mon collègue michel
teulière au nom de notre commission pour
justement pouvoir
après observation de la mise en oeuvre
de la réforme dans sa première phase le
cas échéant ajusté le modèle économique
de l'audiovisuel public
je redis comme nous l'avions dit à
l'époque la clause de revoyure
introduite à l'article 18 par notre
collègue christian iv est un garde-fou
et conformément à ce que nous écrivions
je pense donc aujourd'hui avec mon
collègue de la commission des finances
claude belot sûr je cite les effets
culturel et financier de la diminution
de la publicité sur le service public
car si le comité de suivi que nous
avions fait inscrire à l'article 75 de
la loi n'a hélas pas été mis en place
notre commission et là je tiens à
remercier son président jacques legendre
qui a été très réactif a dès le mois de
novembre dernier décider du coup que
soit mis en place une mission de
contrôle sur l'adéquation des moyens de
france télévisions à ses missions et là
monsieur rallye je tiens à préciser que
cette demande émane strictement de la
commission culture et non de la
commission des finances sous la
domination de laquelle nous ne sommes
pas ce travail que vous m'avez confiées
les chers collègues est l'occasion d'un
bilan d'étape précis de la réforme qui
vivent eu le contexte ne serait être
bâclé vous qui avez tant de fois dénoncé
l'urgence dans laquelle nous avons bien
souvent dû légiférer
je ne vois pas pourquoi il faudrait tout
d'un coup sans élément tangible
d'appréciation se précipiter à modifier
une loi votée il ya tout juste un an
si la situation de france télévisions
reste fragile je vous la corde et
d'ailleurs la cour des comptes le
rapport dans son rapport la souligné
elle n'a pas non
lui pris la tournure dramatique quand
vous lui prédisiez et que vous lui voyez
aujourd'hui monsieur rallye qui
justifierait aujourd'hui votre
éventuelle proposition de rétablir dans
la précipitation la publicité après 20
heures
rappelons qu'en 2009 le financement de
france télévisions a été suffisant pour
que le groupe soit l' équilibre et pour
2010 la contribution à l'audiovisuel
public et la dotation de l'état ont
rassuré l'augmentation des ressources
prévues par le contrat d'objectifs et de
moyens
je veux aussi il a souligné que le
virage éditorial dont chacun se félicite
aujourd'hui a aussi été favorisée par la
suppression de la publicité après 20
heures
pour autant c'est vrai ne vaut pas être
dans l'autosatisfaction il faut rester
prudent il faut étudier avec davantage
de précision
la situation financière de france
télévisions pour accompagner jusqu'au
bout deux chantiers majeurs de la
réforme qui en définitive conditionne
tout le reste c'est une entreprise
commune et de média global il faut aussi
comme le recommande la cour des comptes
préserver l'équipe dirigeante
les atermoiements et revirements qui ont
affecté la stratégie de l'entreprise au
cours des dernières années il n'y a pas
lieu dans tout cas de crier au loup
aujourd'hui et de remettre en cause le
calendrier non plus nous nous étions
fixés pour aborder l'échéance de la
clause de revoyure prévue en mai 2011
dans de bonnes conditions
s'il est important en effet que les
décisions pour l'avenir de la régie
publicitaire soit prise et je me suis
renseigné au plus tard fin 2010 on
notera quand même dans la tente que nos
deux collègues michel thiollière et
christian kert administrateur de france
télévisions au pris toutes les garanties
pour que soit poursuivi la réflexion on
ne votant pas sa privatisation
les décisions quant au financement
l'audiovisuel ne prendra pas en tout
état de cause avant la prochaine loi de
finances à dire à la fin de l'année en
conséquence à moins qu'on ne cherche à
court circuiter sciemment le travail de
fois que nous menons à mon collègue
claude bellot et là je m'interroge où se
trouve la courtoisie si tel était le cas
travail qui lui est rendu avant la fin
de la session parlementaire il me paraît
raisonnable de différer
en la renvoyant l'examen de cette
proposition de loi est cher collègue
cela remet nullement en cause votre
propre travail vos propres appréciations
certaines d'entre elles d'ailleurs vous
le savez nous l'avons dit en commission
nous les partageons monsieur val it vous
me connaissiez vous même d'ailleurs en
commission le 4 mai dernier que le
rapport d'information de monsieur b look
avait été réalisée en 2000 porter un
diagnostic très fin cela venait de
l'audiovisuel public dont ne pensez vous
pas qu'il serait pertinent d'attendre un
peu plus d'un mois et d'obtenir à
nouveau diagnostic qui s'agissant du
même collège ne devrait donc non plus
pas manqué de finesse aux effets de
manche pardonnez-moi au risque de
paraître plus tu es moi je préfère la
rigueur de la démonstration et avant de
voter de nouvelles dispositions
je pense plus sérieux que les
parlementaires puissent avoir
connaissance de toutes les informations
nécessaires de tous les chiffres précis
pour justement assurer au plus juste les
besoins et ressources du groupe public
je tiens d'ailleurs à votre disposition
la liste des personnes que j'ai
auditionné avec mon collègue pas moins
d'une soixantaine pour l'instant des
travaux en cours et des travaux à venir
ne prenons pas donc le risque de vote
aujourd'hui des articles qui ont ce que
ce qui me concerne sans plus de
précision le pose des questions je
prendrai quelques exemples j'ai déjà eu
l'occasion de commenter l'article
d'important sur l'éventuel retour de la
publicité après 20 heures
s'agissant de l'article 3 il me semble
difficile de statuer définitivement sur
la vente de la régie publicitaire tant
que nous n'avons ni confirmer ni
infirmer la suppression totale de la
publicité sur les chaînes de france
télévisions avant 20 heures
l'article 5 je crois notre exemple a
trait à la contribution du visuel vous
nous proposez l'élargissement de son
assiette aux résidences secondaires
proposition d'ailleurs qui émanait de la
commission copé ce qu'a rappelé je crois
que la contribution à l'audiovisuel
public et ses nombreuses et de mes
collègues partagent ce point de vue
mérite une réflexion très cliché sur son
équité et sa modernisation
je crois qu'on peut beaucoup plus
ambitieux concernant votre article 6 qui
porte sur la taxe sur les recettes
publicitaires des chaînes privées
paraissent plus de justice où sont déjà
revenus sur cet axe il ya peu de temps
en l'abaissant à 1,5 pour cent pour
justement éviter aux chaînes privées de
payer pour un effet d'aubaine qui n'a
pas eu lieu
ne seront pas crédibles en proposant dès
maintenant de la passer de 3 5%
vous êtes comme nous très attaché à
l'indépendance de france télévisions
je vous rappelle que dit qu'il dit
indépendance du pouvoir politique dit
aussi l'indépendance de l'expertisé des
besoins de financement je regrette alors
par exemple pour assurer une meilleure
adéquation du financement mission du
groupe
aucun des dispositifs d'évaluation
indépendante et neutre comme cela se
fait en allemagne avec la caisse ne soit
prévu votre proposition
nous avions d'ailleurs fait adopter en
séance au sénat un amendement permettant
un rapport annuel au pied au csa sur le
financement l'audiovisuel public vous
étiez abstenus citer votre choix sur
cette proposition mais je crois que
c'était une bonne idée et que ces
documents a été précieux tout comme je
l'exprimé le dit mais je pense que
autant nous devons nous saisir du débat
en amont comme nous le faisons comme
nous l'avons fait le 10 mai dernier
autant nous devons attendre avant de
décider de revenir ou non sur la loi du
5 mars 2009
d'ici là comme vous vous êtes engagé
monsieur le ministre le gouvernement de
voir à mettre au rap au parlement un
rapport sur l'incident
je vous demande conclure sauf que le 1er
mai 2011 en vente lisions mes chers
collègues je voudrais vous dire que nous
savons tous que la situation a changé du
fait de la crise économique par rapport
à ce qu'elle était début 2008 notamment
le déficit budgétaire s'est creusé de
façon alarmante des paramètres nouveaux
sont également intervenus nous serons de
prendre le croire nos responsabilités le
moment venu celui ci ausy le temps la
discussion budgétaire qui n'est pas si
éloigné pour toutes les raisons que j'ai
donc invoquer je maintiens ce matin ma
demande de renvoi en commission n'ont la
sagesse qui me semble être la marque de
fabrique de notre assemblée tout autant
que la courtoisie je vous remercie de
votre attention vous remercie
la parole est un monsieur david
assouline bien c'est une proposition de
loi qui arrive à un moment où la
question de savoir si l'audiovisuel
public france télévisions doit passer à
une nouvelle étape de sa dépendance
financière consacrant encore plus sa
mise sous tutelle par le pouvoir
politique
en supprimant la publicité y compris
avant 20h est dans le débat public
cette question je le rappelle il n'y a
que deux systèmes qui permettent
l'indépendance financière donc politique
tant vis-à-vis du commerce que de l'état
le premier système
c'est un système d'audio visuel
entièrement financée par la redevance
l'ump ne l'a jamais voulu ça a été
discuté dans la commission copé ou le
deuxième système ce qui prévalait avant
cette réforme un financement par la
redevance qui n'est pas la même chose
que par le budget de l'état et un
financement par la publicité qui
permettait qu'on était dépendant ni de
l'un ni de l'autre par l' équilibre que
cela produisait et ce système vous
rappeler que je les mentionnaient a
fonctionné trouver un équilibre trouvé
une qualité trouver un public et a
permis des changements éditoriaux amorcé
bien avant la réforme de l'année
dernière consacrant la qualité y compris
à des heures de grande écoute
aujourd'hui de se
blême de principe quel est le
financement qui assure l'indépendance et
je veux quand même dire qu à l'épreuve
d'une année quand nous disions la
dépendance financière ça va être une
dépendance politique on ne se trompait
pas car nous connaissons les pressions
que subissent la direction de france
télévisions et différents échelons de
cette direction constamment par le
pouvoir politique aujourd'hui même si
tout n'est pas sur la place publique et
je veux même dire qui hier en regardant
la télévision
j'ai pu constater à 20 heures
comment vous pouvez traiter une chef de
l'opposition par rapport dans le même
exercice d'interview on regarde comment
l'on interview le chef de l'état et avec
quelle complaisance et je me suis dit
que vraiment vraiment j'ai mal pour le
service public quand je vois ça alors il
y à la deuxième raison qui elle est
conjoncturelle c'est que on ne peut pas
expliquer aux français qu il manque 100
milliards dans les caisses de l'état et
que donc il faut se serrer la ceinture
il faut arrêter les dépenses sociales
les réduire et les dépenses publiques
alors que ici et là y'a besoin en de
plus de services publics et de meilleurs
services publics
on ne peut pas leur dire ça et leur dire
que on va aller au bout
en supprimant une recette de 430
millions d'euros avant 20 heures qui a
été apportée d'année dernière en allant
au bout du chemin et supprimant
l'ensemble de la publicité
d'autant que même ce qui était prévu
ça c'est 430 millions en moins cas
rapportés la régie mais les taxes qui
devait permettre à l'état de financer
même le passage actuel seulement après
20 heures ne sont pas au rendez vous
elles ne sont pas au rendez vous
la taxe sur les recettes publicitaires
pas au rendez vous parce qu'avec la
crise les effets le report qui a eu sur
les chaînes privées n'a pas été celui
qui était prévu et donc les rentrées ne
sont pas celles qui étaient prévues
elles sont moindres deuxième recette sur
les télécoms 300 millions pour l'instant
sa rente mais on sait que bruxelles a
attaqué et je le dis ici et on en
reparlera
ce n'est pas une attaque comme ça et la
france va gagner
elle est argumenté elle est nettement
avancé et nous seront sanctionnés donc
ça ne rentrera pas dans les années à
venir et pour les deux années passées il
faudrait rembourser 300 millions à
chaque fois donc voyez le tableau quand
même qu'on soit pas d'accord avec nous
sur le principe en général mais là dans
la conjoncture
y'a pas les rentrées d'argent prévu et
en plus les caisses de l'état sont vides
alors continuez l'entêtement et quelque
chose que je viens demander d'arrêter ne
sera lite avec sa ppl c'est l'essentiel
de ce qu'il propose ne pas supprimer la
publicité avant 20 heures
je veux finir en vous disant aussi qu'
il ya beaucoup de contradictions dans la
façon dont vous avez voulu procéder par
une manne heures sur cette histoire du
renvoi en commission
monsieur khalid a bien développé
en quoi ce n'est pas démocratique et
c'est une manoeuvre qui consacre le fait
majoritaire et qui n'est pas du tout la
tradition de nos moeurs au sénat sur des
questions de ce type mais il ya une
raison
je me suis dit pourquoi vont-ils jusque
là on vote ils sont majoritaires ils
votent contre
mais en réalité vous le savez pourquoi
parce que ce que nous disons la est
partagée par beaucoup de professionnels
et de responsables de la majorité
y compris par le président du groupe ump
à l'assemblée nationale qui a dit lui
même qu'il fallait revoir le fait de
passer à la suppression totale de la
publicité mais comme ce n'est pas encore
arbitré comme vous avez encore un peu
tôt puisque ça se décidera au final que
à peu près avant l'été 2011
vous par une manoeuvre pour convenance
politicienne vous mettez un coup de
canif à une procédure démocratique et ce
n'est pas comme ça que l'on fait la loi
et c'est pas comme ça que l'on sait
vivre la démocratie
je voulais finir en disant cela aux
efforts parce que il en va de l'avenir y
compris des ppl et des droits de
l'opposition qu'on voulait au contraire
consacré quand on a discuté de ces
niches et de ses droits accordés à
l'opposition et pour finir sachez que
l'opposition n'est pas toujours
l'opposition elle peut devenir
majoritaire et ce que je veux vous dire
ici c'est que cette indépendance
vis-à-vis du pouvoir politique que nous
défendons elle n'est pas conjoncturel
c'est aussi pour demain
si un changement de majorité ce sont des
principes démocratiques que nous
défendons ici je vous remercie mes chers
collègues la parole est un monsieur jean
pierre plancade
monsieur le président monsieur monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues
la proposition de loi que nous examinons
ce matin a le mérite de soulever un vrai
véritable problème celui de la pérennité
du financement de france télévisions et
donc je nous trouvons que cette
composition vient fort à propos
ça a permis d'ailleurs monsieur le
ministre de donner des explications plus
longue parce qu'effectivement la
situation financière la situation de
l'état nous préoccupe et et je comprends
le cri de douleur que viennent pousser
jacques khalid et le et ses collègues en
déposant cette proposition de loi parce
que parce que nous savons tous ici et
personne ne met en cause son attachement
au service public et aux séries fiq de
la télévision mais quand je lis les
propositions qui sont en fait une image
qui devient à la tête j'ai l'impression
d'avoir une référence historique je sais
pas si vous vous souvenez de ce stage de
saint pierre le stage de saint pierre
vous savez c'était le chef des bourgeois
de calais qui se dans un acte est un
geste héroïque est arrivé en chemise
l'accord le coup avec cinq autres ses
compatriotes
pour l'heure nous vous donnons notre vie
mais sauver la vie des habitants de
calais est aujourd'hui dans cette même
démarche héroïque intellectuelle quand
on connaît l'origine la proposition de
loi on nous dit pour sauver le service
public
eh bien on va reprendre la manne
financière des entreprises privées voila
voila et je dis quand même temps c'est
un grand cri de couleurs et je comprends
que c'est un acte héroïque et une grande
souffrance
intellectuellement parlant mais moi je
reste et au rdse nous restons sur un
principe simple qui est une activité
privée des fonds privés une activité
publique des fonds publics
voilà alors on est un film sur le
ministre c'est vrai qu'on est inquiet
450 millions on a été ramené à 415 si le
financement
l'absence de publicité nous propose lui
100 millions
don jeudi où va-t-on trouver cet argent
voilà et les inquiétudes est tout à fait
légitime
je vais passer surtout mon texte mais il
y à une solution
il ya là pas 50 parce que créer
l'indépendance financière elle passe par
un seul acte par un seul acte qui
s'appelle la redevance télévisuelle
voilà parce que quand on me dit on va
mettre la publicité comme ça ça assurera
l'indépendance financière non censurée
du tout ça continue a confirmé le diktat
de la publicité sur l'entreprise
publique
et alors je me suis livré à un petit
calcul
aujourd'hui la redevance télévisuelle
c'est 10 euros par mois ce sont les
messieurs 10 euros par mois pour assurer
le financement total sans subventions
publiques sans subventions privées parce
que la publicité au fond peut
l'assimiler à une fondation privée
vous savez combien ça coûterait tous les
mois
trois euros de plus 3 euros de plus et
nous avons tout ce débat pour trois
euros de plus et quand mme morin
dessailly avec monsieur nous rendre un
rapport qui sera excellent parce que
j'en connais le nous en connaissons les
auteurs rapport rapport je le rappelle
rapport je le rappelle qui a été demandé
par l'ensemble de la commission
voilà donc mais ça ne changera rien
catherine ça ne changera rien parce
qu'au bout du bout on va trouver des
chemins de traverse pour financer trois
euros par mois c'est le prix du courage
politique des parlementaires lors et
vous où vous n'aurez pas jusqu'à présent
nous n'avons pas eu et je m'associe et
je m'associe à ça
j'étais un de ceux qui ont soutenu la
progression voilà mais il faut aller
jusqu'au bout de l'acte le bout de la
paix le bout de l'indépendance ces trois
euros de plus par mois pour chaque foyer
fiscal
sachant que 25% en sont exonérés voilà
mesdames et messieurs ce que je voulais
vous dire et vous dire que on ne votera
pas contre des propositions de loi mais
on ne la soutiendra pas on ne la
soutiendra pas non plus parce que nous
pensons que la soupe même s'il ya des
choses pertinentes à l'intérieur de
cette institution
ce qui fait que nous sommes complètement
d'accord mais nous pensons tout de même
que activités publiques fonds publics
activités privées fonds privés voilà
mesdames et messieurs ce que je voulais
vous dire au nom des radicaux de gauche
et de rds
je vous remercie chers collègues la
parole est à monsieur jean louis massot
on
oui monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre chers collègues
bon je voudrais préciser ma position sur
ces problèmes de télévision pour dire
tout d'abord que je crois que nos
concitoyens sont suffisamment disons
pressurés par des par la fiscalité et
notamment les concitoyens les plus
modestes sans qu'ils soient
obligatoirement judicieux de rajouter
des prélèvements sur des impôts ou des
prélèvements qui vont encore au béret
finalement leur situation
la deuxième voire que je préfère c'est
que bien évidemment là disons il faut
assurer il faut garantir l'indépendance
et la liberté totale de la télévision en
général de l'information télévisée en
général et housses et en particulier de
la télévision publique et sur ce point
je ne suis pas totalement persuadé qu'il
n'y ait pas je dirais des influences qui
peuvent exister face à je pense que
c'est propre de tous les gouvernements
mais le gouvernement actuel n'est
certainement pas exempt de toute
pression en la matière et la troisième
remarque c'est pour dire aussi que la
télévision avec la côte et villon
qu'elle soit publique ou privée connaît
des dérives financières extraordinaire
c'est à dire que on assiste à des sommes
engagées qui sont absolument colossal
les chaînes de télévision qu'ils soient
publics ou privés paient des sommes
colossales à haendel ou à d'autres pour
faire des émissions qui sont à ras des
pâquerettes et même parfois en dessous
des pâquerettes
donc c'est à mon avis je crois que ce
qu'il faut voir dans cette affaire la
section ne veut pas relever les mois je
ne le souhaite pas si on ne veut pas
relevé la redevance
bon il faut garantir des ressources
antenne 2 et moi je pense que si l'on
supprime une partie de la publicité et
pour ma part j'étais contre la
suppression de la publicité sur antenne
2 enfin sur france 2 parce que je pense
que les finalités n'était pas
obligatoirement de supprimer la
télévision enfin la publicité sur
antenne 2 c'était plus pour permettre à
certaines chaînes amis du pouvoir de
récupérer des parts de publicité donc je
pense pour ma part que si l'on veut
garantir des ressources aux chaînes
publiques
il faut augmenter les prélèvements sur
les chaînes privées et je le dis avec
d'autant plus de conviction que quand on
voit les sommes qui sont brassés qui
sont brassés gaspillé pour ne rien faire
pour faire des émissions archi-nul
simplement pour enrichir des promoteurs
tels qu'intel ken des molles ou ou payés
à prix d'or ddd des intervenants des
journalistes de tf1 du 20 heures de tf1
ou d'autres choses
eh bien il ya qu un peu moins les payer
il ya qu'à payer un peu moins des bols
et on trouvera les moyens de financer la
télévision publique donc ma position est
très claire je suis hostile au
relèvement de la redevance et je suis
partisan si on ne rétablit pas la
publicité sur les chaînes publiques de
prélèvement beaucoup plus important sur
tf1 et sur un certain nombre d'autres
chaînes privées qui ont des chiffres
d'affaires absolument fabuleux et qui
peuvent très bien supporté un
prélèvement supplémentaire
la parole est à madame colette mélot
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
la proposition de loi qui est
aujourd'hui soumise à notre examen
souligne l'intérêt profond que nous
avons tous pour l'enjeu majeur que
constitue l'avenir de l'audiovisuel
public et plus particulièrement pour les
ressources nécessaires aux missions de
service public télévisuel
toutefois je suis réservé à l'idée de
revenir sur le processus retenu par la
loi du 5 mars 2009 la loi du 5 mars 2009
un peu plus d'une année après son entrée
en vigueur a permis de répondre à une
certaine idée du service public
télévisuel en renouant avec une exigence
culturelle de qualité pour le plus grand
profit de tous les publics la mise en
oeuvre cette réforme est un succès tant
dans son application par les
professionnels que dans la manière dont
elle a été accueillie par les
téléspectateurs
l'une des dispositions phare de cette
réforme salutaire et bien évidemment la
suppression progressive de la publicité
libérer la télévision publique de la
publicité est une nécessité culturelle
mais aussi une nécessité économique car
la publicité n'est pas une manne
inépuisable et la crise nous l'a
confirmé cette mesure de suppression
progressive de la publicité est
largement plébiscitée par les
téléspectateurs qui apprécient que les
programmes de première partie de soirée
puissent débuter dès 20h35 plus de 70%
d'entre eux s'en déclarent satisfaits et
j'ajoute que les programmes de deuxième
et de troisième partie de soirée démarre
eux aussi plutôt et rencontre ainsi une
inclus large public
la loi du 5 mars 2009 prévoit que la
suppression totale de la publicité en
journée sur france télévisions
interviendra au moment où la france aura
entièrement basculer dans la diffusion
numérique c'est à dire à la fin de 2011
ce basculement permettra de réaliser des
économies importantes sur les coûts de
diffusion qui limiteront de temps le
besoin de financement complémentaire
apportés par l'état pour compenser la
suppression de la publicité la loi a
introduit plusieurs dispositions
financières notamment l'indexation sur
l'inflation de la redevance qui présente
l'avantagé d'être la seule ressource
réellement pérenne
je rappelle que la commission de la
culture a depuis longtemps engagé une
réflexion sur la revalorisation de la
redevance dont le montant était gelé
depuis 2001
ce montant est par ailleurs inférieur à
la moyenne constatée dans d'autres pays
d'europe
une augmentation de la redevance
pourrait être le moyen d'accompagner le
passage à la suppression totale de la
publicité
certes monsieur le ministre le débat
ouvert en 2008 sur la contribution à
l'audiovisuel public alors dénommée
redevance audiovisuelle se pose plus
dans les mêmes termes aujourd'hui
puisque ces changements des changements
importants ont eu lieu
le montant de la contribution a été
indexée sur l'inflation à compter de
2009 est porté à 120 euros en 2010 soit
deux euros supplémentaires
en outre le programme qui finance le
passage à la télévision tout numérique
ne fait plus partie des bénéficiaires la
contribution à l'audiovisuel public
nous pourrions réfléchir en ce qui
concerne l'assiette de cette taxe et à
son éventuel élargissement aux nouveaux
modes de réception de la télévision
je rappelle d'autre part que lors de
l'examen du texte la commission de la
culture avait proposé d'étendre la
redevance aux ordinateurs puisque les
habitudes des télés les téléspectateurs
ont changé je crois qu'effectivement il
faudra tenir compte un jour des nouveaux
moyens de consommation de l'offre du
visuel
peut-être serait-il également
souhaitable d'assujettir à la redevance
les propriétaires de résidences
secondaires
ce sont des pistes à étudier pour
garantir l'évolution des ressources de
france télévisions enfin pour terminer
le panorama des ressources dans le
service public dispose il faut citer la
subvention spécifique et nouvelles du
budget de l'état inscrits chaque année
dans le projet de loi de finances comme
vous l'avez démontré monsieur le
ministre le remplacement d'une recette
publicitaire incertaine par une recette
public assuré constitue évidemment un
facteur de sérénité financière éditorial
pour france télévisions le montant de la
ressource publique à prévoir pour les
années 2009 à 2012 figurent dans
l'avenant au contrat d'objectifs et de
moyens conclu entre la société et l'état
il tient compte l'ensemble des
paramètres dont la suppression de la
publicité en soirée en 2009 et à la fin
de 2011
en journée à l'extinction de
l'analogique prévue fin 2011 et avec la
suppression de la publicité en journée
la part des ressources publiques
devraient représenter plus de 95% des
ressources du groupe
il faut rappeler que nous sommes dans un
moment technologique particulier celui
de la révolution du numérique de l'usagé
d'internet date généralisation de la tnt
gratuite qui permet à chaque français de
recevoir plus de 20 chaînes elle oblige
le service public à se réinventer pour
les années à venir nous devons donc être
vigilants sur la question de son
financement nécessaire pour faire de
france télévision un média global
capable de réunir tous les publics sur
tous les supports de diffusion
la loi crée les conditions de cette
transformation en organisant le groupe à
une entreprise unique
en créant le maximum de synergies par la
mutualisation des moyens
cette simplification et cette
rationalisation des structures sont le
gage d'une plus grande efficacité du
groupe et d'une force accrue sur le
marché
je voudrais maintenant évoquer
l'actualité est l'idée qui circule
actuellement de ne pas réaliser la
prochaine étape prévue par la loi la
suppression totale de la publicité sur
france télévisions qui signifierait
pourtant la suppression totale de la
dépendance aux ressources publicitaires
je suis assez surprise que la question
soit posée alors que cette décision a
été prise à l'issue d'une longue
réflexion
compte tenu de l'incertitude
substantielle entourant le maintien ou
non de la publicité avant 20 heures
je regrette mais approuve la définition
du conseil d'administration de france
télévisions de suspendre les
négociations engagées pour céder sa
régie publicitaire france télévisions
publicité
à ce jour c'est suis pour ma part
favorable à la suppression totale de la
publicité sur la télévision publique
il me semble nécessaire de pouvoir dit
la distinguer des chaînes commerciales
et lui donner ce que j'appellerais une
couleur montrer sa valeur particulier
1 son apport pédagogique et culturel la
question me semble surtout prématurée
une seule année s'est écoulée
la crise économique s'est invitée au
moment où la réforme était votée et ne
disposons pas d'un bilan très précis
certes la loi a prévu que le comité de
suivi ferait un point d'étape régulier
de l'application de la loi et qu'un
groupe de travail soit redevance eau
division audiovisuel serait constitué
mais la mise en place de ce dispositif a
pris du retard et des études nous manque
j'ajouterai que le groupe france
télévisions a été à l'équilibré en 2009
et la dotation 2010 respecte le contrat
d'objectifs et de moyens dans le rapport
établi il ya quelques mois mes collègues
michel thiollière et catherine morin
desailly estimé qu' à court terme
avec l'arrivée du média global ayant
vocation à réunir tous les publics
il faudrait faire face à des coûts qu'il
faisait l'objet d'aucune évaluation
sérieuse
il avait donc proposé dans un amendement
qui fut votée par le sénat
un audit annuel par le csa sur le
financement de l'audiovisuel public
la disposition a disparu en cmp et c'est
regrettable car le document aurait été
précieux notre haute assemblée a pour sa
part créé une mission d'information sur
le financement de france télévisions
commune à la commission des finances et
à la commission
la culture d'éducation et de la
communication est là pour le moment
procéder à une trentaine d'auditions et
devait publier ses conclusions au début
de l'été comme catherine morin desailly
l'a précisé
il me semble plus opportun d'attendre
les conclusions de cette mission avant
d'ouvrir un débat sur les suites de la
réforme par conséquent conclut groupe
ump favorables à l'adoption d'une motion
de renvoi en commission afin que nous
examinions ce sujet d'importance en
disposant d'éléments supplémentaires
dans une démarche rigoureuse et dans un
esprit de coopération entre les groupes
politiques
pour conclure je souhaite réaffirmer ma
confiance dans notre service public pour
mettre à la portée du plus grand nombre
d'informations la culture et la création
avec la réforme nous avons donné à
france télévisions là
possibilité d'une programmation plus
audacieuse et je pense que nous lui
avons permis d'affirmer son identité
dans un secteur où deux audiovisuel en
pleine mutation
merci je vous remercie mme asha
collègues mes chers collègues
suite aux décisions et décision prise
hier soir en conférence des présidents
je vous informe que je suspendrai la
séance avant 13 heures à 13 heures
précises
d'ailleurs nous avons une séance de
questions d'actualité à 15 heures
précises également mes jeux j'observe la
décision de la conférence des présidents
la parole est à nous suivre en renard
monsieur le président messieurs me
disent mes chers collègues contrairement
à ce qui s'est dit ici il ya dix jours
et encore ce matin
il ya véritablement urgence adopté de
véritables dispositions relatives à la
télévision publique
comme a pu le développer mon ami jacques
khalid la télévision et dans son
financement est donc dans son
indépendance gravement menacée
c'est pourquoi notre proposition de loi
ne se contente pas de faire un bilan de
l'application de la loi du 9 mars 2009
qui a bouleversé les équilibres
économiques de france télévisions elle
en tire les conséquences et propose des
solutions avant qu'il ne soit trop tard
car oui il est indispensable que le
groupe france télévisions possède dès
aujourd'hui et non pas comme prévu par
la clause de revoyure en 2011 des
éléments constitutifs et déterminant de
l'élaboration de la stratégie de
développement à savoir le maintien de
ses ressources publicitaires la
télévision publique demain se construit
aujourd'hui en fonction du projet et de
la visibilité que nous lui donnons en
déterminant par les textes que nouveau
temps les financements nécessaires et
adéquates
nous avons véritablement le devoir et la
responsabilité vous de décider sans
tarder pour qu'un véritable service
public télévisuel
digne de ce nom puisse encore et pour
longtemps trouvé sa place dans la
société française
pour cela afin de sortir france
télévisions des ornières dans lesquels
la loi du mars 2009le embourbé nous
proposons aujourd'hui un plan de
sauvetage en six mesures détaillées dans
les six articles d'autres lois que
jacques a rappelé tout à l'heure une de
nos propositions consiste à maintenir la
publicité en journée sur france
télévisions
même après 2011 une publicité
naturellement sévèrement encadrée et
vous aurez remarqué comme moi que loin
d'être partisane
cette proposition transcende
actuellement les appartenances
politiques
et pour cause elle est combinée au
financement par la redevance
télévisuelle et par les dotations de
l'état la seule assurer les moyens
nécessaires à la sauvegarde de france
télévisions et elle permet aux débats de
sortir de sa béatitude conflictuelle
j'en profite ici pour affirmer même si
cela va de soi que nous ne sommes
évidemment pas en tant que tel des
défenseurs de la publicité des intérêts
privés des marchands du temple du temple
nous sommes les défenseurs d'une
télévision publique indépendante qui
dispose de financements nécessaires à
son développement à l'accomplissement
ses missions propres et au maintien de
programmes de qualité et cette vision là
ne serait actuellement exister sans les
revenus liés aux ressources
publicitaires
à défaut d'une redevance à la hauteur on
ne le répétera jamais assez
ses revenus sont en plus indispensable
qu'en période de crise et de déficit et
atic colossaux le gouvernement vient
d'annoncer un plan d'austérité sans
précédent qui vient s'ajouter la
désormais fameuse fameuse et sinistre
révision générale des dépenses publiques
dont la culture comme d'autres secteurs
de la vie sociale font les frais
particulièrement par la suppression du
nombre d'emplois aggravant les
inégalités sociales d'une société où le
tout d un effet du rien d autre dès lors
comment croire que l'état aura les
moyens pour ne pas dire la volonté de
compenser cette diminution de ressources
qui ne ferait qu'aggraver s'aggraver
avec la suppression totale
de la publicité en 2011 c'est la fin de
cette séance si vous souhaitez la revoir
notre site internet publicsenat.fr à
suivre le journal de 18h présenté ce
soir par caroline delage bonne soirée à
tous sur public sénat